NIGHT, STAY SAFE, GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WHEN THE MOBS CAME,
THEY ABANDON US.
IF WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT," THE
NATION WENT UP IN FLAMES THIS
WEEKEND.
I WENT IN CHARGE STOOD UP TO
SAVE AMERICA.
THEY DID THIRD AND THEY COWERED
AND THEY OPENLY SIDED WITH THE
DESTROYERS AND MANY CASES THEY
EXITED THEM ON.
LATER, THEY DENY DOING ANY OF
THIS AND THEY’RE DENYING IT NOW.
YOU KNOW THE TRUTH BECAUSE YOU
SAW IT HAPPEN AND THIS IS WHEN
NATIONS CLASSED WHEN NOBODY END
AUTHORITY KEEPS ORDER.
AMERICAN CITIZENS ARE FORCED TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES AND THEY HAVE
NO CHOICE.
NO ONE WILL DEFEND THEM THEY
KNOW THAT NOW.
IT’S POSSIBLE THAT MORE PEOPLE
WILL BE HURT IN THE COMING DAYS
AND THAT’LL BE A TRAGEDY.
IF AN ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS,
MORE VIOLENCE CAN LEAD TO A
CASCADE OF NEW TRAGEDIES.
SOMETHING FAR BIGGER AND MORE
DESTRUCTIVE THAN ANYTHING WE’VE
SEEN SO FAR.
THIS ISN’T OVER AND IT MIGHT
SIMPLY BE UP AT THE BEGINNING IT
ISN’T.
IT’S HARD TO THINK CLEARLY ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT’S GOING ON, THE
CHAOS, THE DESTRUCTION, AND IT’S
ALL TOO MUCH.
IF AMERICANS ARE BILL WELD
BILLABLE DIRTY AND AFRAID BUT
MOST OF OUR THEY ARE FILLED WITH
RAGE.
ANGRIER THAN THEY HAVE EVER BEEN
IN THE WORST PEOPLE IN OUR
SOCIETY HAVE TAKEN CONTROL.
THEY DID NOTHING TO BUILD THE
COUNTRY AND NOW THEY ARE TEARING
IT DOWN.
THEY’RE RUSHING US TOWARDS MASS
SUICIDE.
HOW DO WE RESPOND?
WE MUST PROTECT OURSELVES AND
OUR FAMILIES AND ONCE AGAIN WE
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO DO THAT.
BUT WE CANNOT ALLOW OURSELVES TO
BECOME LIKE THEY ARE.
YOU’RE NOT ANIMALS, WE ARE
AMERICANS.
IN THE FACE OF SUCH INDECENCY,
WE MUST RESOLVE TO BE DECENT.
WE BELIEVE THIS COUNTRY HAS A
FUTURE WE INTEND OUR CHILDREN TO
LIVE AND THRIVE HERE.
IF THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
DEFENDING.
ALL OUR LEADERS DO IS SET US
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
THEY STAYED IN AND YOU BACK
NEVER ENDING FIGHT FOR THEIR
PROFIT AND AMUSEMENT.
WE WILL NOT PLAY ALONG AND WE
LOVE OUR NEIGHBORS RELENTLESSLY
NOT BECAUSE THEY LOOK LIKE US OR
SHARE A VIEW’S BUT WE LOVE THEM
BECAUSE THEY’RE HUMAN BEINGS AND
AMERICANS.
THOSE ARE THE BONDS THAT TIE US
TOGETHER AND THE BONDS THE
LEADERS SEEK TO DESTROY AND WE
CAN’T LET THEM.
WE SHOULD START BY BEING ON
SPARINGLY HONEST ABOUT WHAT’S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND THE
TRUTH IS IN A COUNTRY’S LAST
HOPE, WE PLAN TO USE TONIGHT SO
IT CREATED THE RECORD OF THIS
MOMENT RIGHT NOW.
SHOWING YOU WHAT’S REALLY GOING
ON IN YOUR COUNTRY AND FEEL AN
OBLIGATION TO DO THAT BEFORE THE
FACTS ARE SPUN INTO PROPAGANDA
BY THE LIARS, THE IMAGES PULLED
OFF THE INTERNET INEVITABLY AS
THEY WILL BE.
WE BEGIN THAT WERE MY FAMILY HAS
LIVED FOR 35 YEARS IN THE
NORTHWEST QUADRANT OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THIS IS MARKET ON THE BOULEVARD
WHICH IS NAMED AFTER
GENERAL MacARTHUR IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD STORE.
WALKING DISTANCE FOR MY HOUSE
AND PEOPLE ME THERE EVERY
MORNING FOR COFFEE.
KIDS COME AFTER SCHOOL FOR
CANDY.
IT’S AS CLOSE TO A COMMUNITY
GATHERING SPOT AS WE HAVE.
THE MARKETS RUN BY THE KIM
FAMILY, THE KIM’S ARE IMMIGRANTS
FROM KOREA AND THEY ARE REVERED
AND OUR NEIGHBORHOOD FOR THE
DECENCY IN THE HARDWARE.
THEY LOST THEIR SON SEVERAL
YEARS AGO AND THE NEIGHBORS
GRIEVED FOR THEM.
THE KIM’S ARE NOT POLITICAL AND
THEY NEVER HURT ANYONE.
THEY ONLY MAKE THINGS BETTER.
BUT LAST NIGHT, THE MOB CAME FOR
THEIR STORY.
AT 1:00 A.M. THIS MORNING,
MR. KIM WAS KNEELING ALONE ON
THE SIDEWALK TRYING TO SALVAGE
WHAT HE SPENT HIS LIFE BUILDING.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS PLAYED OUT IN
HUNDREDS OF NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY, MAY BE YOURS.
HERE ARE A FEW.
NORTH CAROLINA, MA’AM CALLED THE
POLICE WHEN THINGS BEGAN TO FALL
APART AND WRITERS SAW HIM CALL
AND THEY SURROUNDED THE MAN AND
THEY BEAT HIM.
ONLOOKERS LAUGHED AS HE WAS
PUMMELED.
>> HE’S ABOUT TO GET ON HIS
BELIEF [BLEEP].
OH, NO!
[BLEEP]!
>> Tucker: ROCHESTER,
NEW YORK, EIGHT MEN SMASHED THE
WINDOWS OF A JEWELRY STORE AND A
COUPLE EMERGE TO CONFRONT THEM.
IF BOTH OF THEM WERE VICIOUSLY
BEATEN WITH A LADDER IN A TWO BY
FOUR.
>> [BLEEP] [BLEEP].
>> GET AWAY FROM MY WIFE!
>> Tucker: IN DALLAS, A MAN
ARMED WITH WHAT APPEARED TO BE A
SORT DID HIS BEST TO DEFEND THE
BUSINESS FROM LOOTERS.
THE MOB BASHED HIM IN THE HEAD
WITH A ROCK AND A SKATEBOARD.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
[BLEEP], [BLEEP]!
[BLEEP]!
[BLEEP][BLEEP], [BLEEP]!
>> Tucker: IT’S HARD TO WATCH.
IN SAN JOSE, RIOTERS STORMED THE
HIGHWAY AND ATTACKED VEHICLES
TRYING TO PULL DRIVERS FROM
THEIR CARS.
>> [BLEEP], GET THE [BLEEP] OUT
THE, GET [BLEEP] OUT.
YOU’RE ABOUT [BLEEP]
[INDISTINCT]
>> Tucker: IN BIRMINGHAM,
ALABAMA, A LOCAL REPORTER NAMED
STEPHEN QUINN WAS BEATEN AND
ROBBED ON LIVE TELEVISION AS HE
TRIED TO COVER THE NEWS.
>> THAT IS A HORRIBLE --
SEEN THAT
YOU SEE RIGHT THERE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
STEPHEN IS ALL RIGHT.
>> Tucker: PORTLAND, OREGON, A
MAN WAS BEATEN APPARENTLY FOR
DARING TO CARRY AN AMERICAN FLAG
IN PUBLIC.
HE NEVER RELEASED THE FLAG, BY
THE WAY.
>> IT’S PEOPLE LIKE YOU --
[INDISTINCT]
>> NO, NO, NO!
>> STOP IT!
>> Tucker: HOW MANY OF THESE
PEOPLE DIED?
HOW MANY WERE MURDERED BY THE
RIOTERS, AND THAT THE LEAST SOME
ARE LIKELY DISABLED FOR LIFE.
THERE WOULD BEATEN THAT BADLY
AND MASS DEALING SEEMS TO BE
EVERYWHERE.
AN UPSCALE PART OF ATLANTA,
RIOTERS STOLE A TESLA FROM A
DEALERSHIP AND DROVE IT THROUGH
A INDOOR MALL AND UNDERSCORING
UNDERHOW WILL COMPLETELY IT WAS
OF CONTROL.
APPLE, CHASE BANK,
LOUIS VUITTON, AND SETTING FIRES
AS THEY LEFT.
>> OH, [BLEEP]!
>> Tucker: AND CHICAGO,
PROTESTERS FOUGHT SYSTEMIC
RACISM BY RUNNING TO A NIKE
STORE STEALING SHOES.
>> GO, GO, GO, GO!
>> Tucker: AND IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., A FEDERAL CITY
SURROUNDED BY MILITARY BASES AND
PROTECT AT ALL TIMES BY THE
SINGLE HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE WORLD,
CRIMINALS OPERATED WITH IMPAIRED
IMPUNITY IN THE STREETS AND THEY
LOOTED GEORGETOWN LAST NIGHT.
AT LEAST MATCH THE WINDOWS IN
THE FEDERAL BUILDING AND THEY
DESECRATED VIRTUALLY EVERY WAR
MEMORIAL IN THE CITY A WEEK
AFTER MEMORIAL DAY.
AS YOU LIKELY KNOW, LAST NIGHT
THEY SET FIRE TO ST. JOHN’S
EPISCOPAL CHURCH UP WITH A
200-YEAR-OLD BUILDING THAT
WELCOMED EVERY AMERICAN
PRESIDENT FROM JAMES MADISON AND
RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THREE PEOPLE STUCK INSIDE,
ANYWHERE DURING THIS INSANITY,
SICK, THE ELDERLY, THE
POWERLESS, THE EXPERIENCE WAS
TERRIFYING.
LISTEN TO THIS WOMAN FROM
MINNEAPOLIS.
>> HOW WAS LAST NIGHT?
>> SCARY.
THEY WENT STRAIGHT TO OFFICEMAX,
THE DOLLAR STORE, AND EVERY
STORY OVER HERE THAT I GO TO.
I HAD NOWHERE TO GO NOW.
I HAVE NO WAY TO GET ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: THAT’S WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
WE DIDN’T PLAY ALL THE TAPE WE
HAVE, THERE’S A LOT OF IT.
SOME OF THE TAPE IS TOO SHOCKING
AND HONESTLY IT’S TOO INCENDIARY
AND YOU UNDERSTAND TELEVISION IS
EMOTIONAL MEDIUM AND WE DO NOT
WANT TO MAKE THINGS WORSE.
BUT HE AT THE POINT IN THE POINT
IS THIS IS A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AND IT’S A PROFOUND NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
BUT YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW THAT
FROM LISTENING TO THE ELECTED
LEADERS IN ALMOST ALL OF THEM
PRETEND THIS IS NOT REALLY
HAPPENING AND IF IT IS HAVE A
DAY, IT’S PART OF THE AMERICAN’S
LONG TRADITION OF VIGOROUS
POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
POLITICIANS ON BOTH SIDES TELL
US THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE DEATH
OF A MAN IN POLICE CUSTODY LAST
WEEK.
PEOPLE TURNING OUR COUNTRY ARE
PROTESTERS AND THEY’RE ENGAGED
IN A LEGITIMATE PROTEST.
OKAY, WHAT EXACTLY ARE THE
PROTESTERS DEMANDS?
WHAT ARE THEY ASKING FOR WAS MAG
IF CONGRESS AGREED TONIGHT TO
ENACT THE PROGRAM, WHAT WITH THE
PROGRAM BE?
NOT A SINGLE PERSON ANSWER
BECAUSE THERE’S ON THE ANSWER.
NO ONE BOTHERED TO POLL THE GUYS
BEATING UP OLD LADIES ON THE
STREET WHERE IT LOOTING THE
CHURCHES BUT YOU HAVE TO HOW
MANY OF THEM HAVE EVEN HEARD OF
GEORGE FLOYD.
IF THEY HAVE HEARD OF THEM, WHAT
DIFFERENCE WOULD IT MAKE?
VIOLENCE AND LOOTING ARE NOT
FORMS OF POLITICAL EXPRESSION.
IF YOU’RE KILLED TOMORROW, HOW
MANY BUILDINGS WOULD YOU WANT
BURNED TO THE GROUND IN YOUR
MEMORY?
HOW MANY OLD WOMEN SMASHED IN
THE FACE ON THE STREET IN YOUR
NAME?
NONE, WE HELP, BECAUSE YOU’RE
NOT A VICIOUS CYCLE PATH LIKE
THE PEOPLE YOU JUST WATCHED.
IN FACT WHAT WERE WATCHING IS
NOT A POLITICAL PROTEST IT’S THE
OPPOSITE OF THE POLITICAL
PROTEST AND IF THE ATTACK ON THE
IDEA OF POLITICS AND THE WRITERS
YOU SEE ARE TRYING TO TOPPLE THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM AND THAT’S HOW
WE RESOLVE OUR DIFFERENCES
WITHOUT USING VIOLENCE BUT THE
PEOPLE WANT A NEW SYSTEM, ONE
GOVERNED BY FORCE.
DO WHAT WE SAY OR WE WILL HURT
YOU.
YOU KNOW THIS AND YOU CAN SEE IT
FOR YOURSELF ON TELEVISION AND
YOU HAVE, BUT OUR LEADERS
CONTINUE TO LIE AND THEY TELL US
IT’S NOT TRUE AND THIS ISN’T
HAPPENING.
IT’S JUST A PROTEST.
SOME DEMOCRATS OPENLY EMBRACED
WHAT’S HAPPENING AND THEY DON’T
HAVE MUCH OF A CHOICE.
THESE ARE THE VOTERS CLEANING
OUT THE ROLEX DOOR AND THERE BIG
JOE BIDEN RALLY EVER.
IF A DOZEN STAFFERS DONATED
MONEY TO THE RIOTERS.
NO DEMOCRAT CAN COMMENTS ON
SOMETHING.
THEY RELEASED THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENT ON TWITTER AND WE’RE
QUOTING "RIOTERS ARE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE CITIES MARCH TOWARDS
PROGRESS.
"PROGRESS.
BURNING BUILDINGS, TEARGAS, DEAD
BODIES, THE SCREAMING INJURY TO,
CRIMINAL ANARCHY.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF FAIRFAX
THAT’S CALLED PROGRESS.
CELEBRITY AFTER CELEBRITY HAS
WEIGHED IN TO AGREE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
FROM HIS COMPOUND TO COME OUT
LeBRON JAMES USED HIS ACCOUNT
TO ENCOURAGE MORE WRITING AND
BERNIE SANDERS HAS DONE THE SAME
AND SO HAS BLACK LIVES MATTER
LEADER HAS.
THEY WILL LAND ON DEATH YEARS HE
SAYS APPROVINGLY.
IMAGINE SHOUTING FIRE IN A
CROWDED THEATER, A THEATER WITH
325 MILLION PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHAT THEY’VE BEEN DOING
AND HAVE BEEN DOING FOR DAYS.
WHEN THE VIOLENCE BEGAN COME UP
WILL BE NEEDED MORE THAN
ANYTHING WAS CLARITY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS.
IT’S HARD TO SEE WHEN THE TEAR
GAS STARTS.
THERE SOMEONE IN AMERICA NEEDED
TO TELL THE TRUTH TO THE COUNTRY
COUNTRY.
INSTEAD, ALMOST ALL OF OUR
CONSERVATIVE LEADERS JOINED THE
LENGTHS DISCOURSE AS IF ON CUE.
ON FRIDAY COME AMERICAN CITIES
WERE BEING DESTROYED BY MOBS AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES REFUSED TO SAY
ANYTHING SPECIFIC ON THE RIGHTS
WE WERE WATCHING ON TELEVISION
AND INSTEAD MIKE PENCE SCOLDED
AMERICA FOR HIS RACISM.
ONCE A LEADING REPUBLIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE TWEETED
"IT’S WHITE AMERICA THAT WE MUST
SEE THE TRUTH SPEAK THE TRUTH
AND ACT ON THE TRUTH.
"MEANWHILE, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
HERITAGE FOUNDATION WITH THE
LARGEST CONSERVATIVE THINK TANK
IN THE COUNTRY, HE MAY HAVE SENT
THEM MONEY AND HOPEFULLY FOR THE
LAST TIME, JAMES HAD A LONG
SCREEN DENOUNCING AMERICA IS A
IRREDEEMABLY RACIST NATION.
"HOW MANY TIMES WILL PROTEST
HAVE TO OCCUR?
"HAVE TO OCCUR, LIKE THE REST OF
OUR SINFULNESS.
THE MESSAGES ON THE RIGHT AND
FROM THE LEFT LEADERS, DON’T
BLAME YOU DESERVE WHAT’S
HAPPENING TO YOU.
NO ONE JUMPED AND MORE
FORCEFULLY OR SEEMED ANGRY AT AN
AMERICA THAN FORMER
SOUTH CAROLINA GOVERNOR AND
"TONIGHT I TURNED ON THE NEWS
AND I’M HEARTBROKEN.
IT’S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD’S
PERSONAL AND PAINFUL FOR ME.
IN ORDER TO HEAL, HE NEEDS TO BE
PERSONAL AND PAINFUL FOR
EVERYONE."
BUT, WAIT A SECOND YOU MAY BE
WONDERING, HOW MY "TO PERSONALLY
RESPONSIBLE WAS QUOTED FOR THE
BEHAVIOR OF A MINNEAPOLIS POLICE
OFFICER, I’VE NEVER BEEN TO
MINNEAPOLIS MAY THINK AND WHY IS
SOME POLITICIAN TELLING ME I’M
REQUIRED TO BE UPSET ABOUT THIS?
THOSE ARE GOOD QUESTIONS AND
IT’S NOT HER STRONG SUIT OVER
CHOIR THINKING AND WHAT SHE DOES
BEST IS MORAL BLACKMAIL.
DURING THE 2016 CAMPAIGN SHE
COMPARED DONALD TRUMP TO THE
RACIST MASS MURDER DYLAN RUPE.
HOW IS DONALD TRUMP SIMILAR TO A
SERIAL KILLER?
SHE NEVER EXPLAINED THAT AND
SHE’S NOT TRYING TO EDUCATE
ANYONE, AND THEIR ONLY GOAL WAS
POLITICAL ADVANTAGE AND
NIKKI HALEY IS EXCEPTIONALLY
GOOD AND GETTING WHAT SHE WANTS
AND SHE’S HAPPY TO DENOUNCE YOU
AS A RACIST IN ORDER TO GET IT.
SHE JUST DID.
IN THIS CASE, NIKKI HALEY’S WISH
CAME TRUE AND THE RIOTERS WERE
PERSONAL AND PEOPLE FOR
EVERYONE.
THE PAIN KEPT INCREASING AND TWO
DAYS AFTER SHE WROTE THAT DOZEN
OF AMERICAN CITIES HAVE BEEN
THOROUGHLY TRASHED AND SOME
DESTROYED.
IF A COUNTRY ALREADY ON THE
BRINK OF RECESSION FACED
ECONOMIC COLLAPSE AND THE
ALREADY FIERCE FULL POPULATIONS
AND THE LOCKED ON FOR MONTHS HAD
BEEN THOROUGHLY AND COMPLETELY
TERRORIZED.
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED, LET’S HOPE
NIKKI HALEY IS PLEASED WE HAVE A
TOME TO BE TO HOUSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION RESPONDING TO THE
HORRORS GOING AROUND US?
WELL, THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR ROBERT O’BRIEN DID A
LIVE INTERVIEW AND HERE’S HOW IT
BEGAN.
>> FIRST THING I’M TO SAY, ON
BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT, OUR
HEARTS AND PRAYERS ARE GOING OUT
AND WE MOURN WITH THEM AND WE
AGREE WITH THEM AND IT’S
HORRIFIC AND I DON’T KNOW WHAT
THE POOR FAMILIES GOING THROUGH
AS THE VIDEO IS PLAYED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND THAT THE TRAGIC
THING AND THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT FROM THE STUDY.
WE ARE WITH THE FAMILY AND IS
THE PRESIDENT SIDE, WHERE WITH
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
>> Tucker: WE ARE WITH THE
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS, AND CAN YOU
BE MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT THAT?
WHO ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
IS A PEOPLE SPITTING FOAM AS
THEY SCREAM F THE POLICE AND IS
AT THE ONE SITTING NEXT TO
THE ARSONIST DOING NOTHING IS
A SET FIRE TO THE BUILDING AND
THE KIDS LAUGHING AS THEY FILMED
THE LOOTING AND THE BEATINGS ON
THEIR iPHONES?
MAY BE FAMOUS PEOPLE IN L.A. WHO
ARE RAISING MONEY ONLINE TO
SUPPORT THE RIOTS.
THEY’RE ALL JUST PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS, YOUNG, WE SUPPORT
THAT THAT’S WHO WE ARE.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND
WHERE IS HE DURING ALL THIS?
FRIDAY NIGHT AFTER THE SHOW, THE
CAMERA MEN HEADED TO LAFAYETTE
SQUARE AND WHAT SHE DID THE
COVER WHAT’S HAPPENING OUTSIDE
THE WHITE HOUSE.
HERE’S WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
>> YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT IT’S LIKE
TO BE A BLACK MAN!
>> FOX NEWS REPORTERS GETTING
CHASED OUT BY THE GEORGE FLOYD
PROTESTERS HERE AT THE PARK AND
THIS ONE IS BEING THROWN IN THE
REPORTERS.
THEY THREW THE MIC AT THE
REPORTER HERE AND AS YOU SEE,
THE PROTEST.
>> Tucker: THAT’S AT LAFAYETTE
SQUARE IN THE CENTER OF THE
CAPITAL CITY.
A THE TAPE RAISED A TROUBLING
QUESTION AND IF YOU CAN’T KEEP A
FOX NEWS CORRESPOND IT FROM
GETTING ATTACKED DIRECTLY ACROSS
THE STREET FROM YOUR HOUSE HOW
CAN YOU PROTECT MY FAMILY?
HOW DO YOU PROTECT THE COUNTRY?
HOW ARE YOU TRYING?
TWITTER THE NEXT MORNING THE
PRESIDENT REASSURED AMERICA THAT
HE AND HIS FAMILY WERE JUST
FINE.
FEDERALLY FUNDED BY THE GUARDS
HAVE KEPT THEM SAFE.
IF HE DID NOT MENTION PROTECTING
THE REST OF THE NATION MUCH OF
WHICH HAS BEEN ON FIRE AND HE
SEEMED AWARE OF ONLY OF HIMSELF.
FOR PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
DONALD TRUMP AND VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP AND SUPPORT HIS
POLICIES, WHO’VE DEFENDED HIM
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AGAINST THE
MOST ABSURD KINDS OF SLANDER,
THIS WAS A DISTRESSING MOMENT.
THE FIRST REQUIREMENT OF
LEADERSHIP IS THAT YOU WATCH
OVER THE PEOPLE IN YOUR CARE.
THAT’S WHAT SOLDIERS WANT FROM
THEIR OFFICERS, IT’S WHAT
FAMILIES NEED FROM THEIR FATHERS
FATHERS.
IT’S WHAT VOTERS DEMAND FROM
THEIR PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE WILL PUT UP WITH ALMOST
ANYTHING IF YOU DO THAT, YOU CAN
REGULARLY SAY THINGS ON
TELEVISION AND HIGHER OMAROSA TO
WORK AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND THAT
WILL BE FORGIVEN IF YOU PROTECT
YOUR PEOPLE.
BUT IF YOU DO NOT PROTECT THEM
OR WORSE THAN THAT, LIKE YOU
CAN’T BE BOTHERED TO PROTECT
THEM, THEN YOU ARE DONE.
IT’S OVER.
PEOPLE WILL NOT FORGIVE
WEAKNESS, THAT’S THE ONE THING
AND BY THE WAY THAT’S NOT A
PARTISAN POINT, IT’S HUMAN
NATURE.
NERO IS THE ONLY ROMAN EMPIRE
WHOSE NAME MOST PEOPLE STILL
REMEMBER.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE ABANDON HIS NATION
AND YEARS OF CRISIS AND 2,000
YEARS LATER WE DON’T FORGIVE HIM
HIM.
DONALD TRUMP’S RESPONSE TO THE
RIOTS WHICH IS ONGOING IS THE
SINGULAR TEST OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
IN AN HOUR AGO HE ANNOUNCED HE
WAS GOING TO MARSHAL ALL
AVAILABLE FORCES MILITARY AND
CIVILIAN TO STOP THE RIOTS.
>> IF THE CITY OR STATE REFUSES
TO TAKE THE ACTIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO DEFEND THE LIFE AND
PROPERTY OF THEIR RESIDENCE,
THEN I WILL DEPLOY THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY AND
QUICKLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM FOR
THEM.
>> Tucker: GOOD FOR HIM.
AFTER THAT ADDRESS, THE
PRESIDENT WALKED OVER TO
ST. JOHN’S WHICH AS WE TOLD YOU
WAS BURNING FEWER THAN 24 HOURS
AGO AND THAT PROVIDED A POWERFUL
SYMBOLIC ESTER AND A DECLARATION
THAT THIS COUNTRY, OUR NATIONAL
SYMBOL AND HER OLDEST
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOT BE
DESECRATED AND DEFEATED BY
NIHILISTIC DESTRUCTION.
WE FERVENTLY HOPE THIS ALL
WORKS.
WHAT AMERICANS WANT MOST RIGHT
NOW IS THE END TO THIS CHAOS AND
THEY WANT THEIR CITIES TO BE
SAFE AND THEY WANT US TO STOP
IMMEDIATELY.
IF THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF CAN’T
STOP US, HE WILL LOSE IN
NOVEMBER AND THE LEFT WILL BLAME
HIM FOR THE ATROCITIES THEY
ENCOURAGED AND VOTERS WILL
AGREE.
IF DONALD TRUMP IS THE PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT SAVE
COUNTRIES AND THAT’S THEIR JOB
AND THAT’S WHY WE HIRE THEM.
IT’S THAT SIMPLE.
SOME KIA ADVISORS AROUND THE
PRESIDENT DON’T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND THE GRAVITY OF THE
MOMENT IN THE MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS THEY’LL TELL YOU,
OPERATORS AREN’T GOING ANYWHERE
IN THE TRAILER PARKS ARE
ROCK-SOLID.
WHAT CHOICE DO THEY HAVE?
THEY HAVE TO VOTE FOR US.
IF JARED KUSHNER ON ONE HAND
MADE THE POINT OUT LOUD.
IF NO ONE HAS MORE CONTEMPT FOR
DONALD TRUMP’S VOTERS THAN
JARED KUSHNER AND NO ONE
ACCESSES IT MORE FREQUENTLY.
HIS VIEWS REMAIN FUNDAMENTALLY
UNCHANGED TODAY.
BUT THE PRESIDENT AIMLESSLY A
SHARP INSTINCT AND THE ONE THAT
WON IS THE PRESIDENCY ALMOST FOU
YEARS AGO HAVE BEEN SINCE
SEPARATED AT EVERY LEVEL BY
JARED KUSHNER AND THE STRENGTH
IMMIGRATION, FOREIGN POLICY, AND
ESPECIALLY ON LAW ENFORCEMENT.
CRIME IN THIS COUNTRY CONTINUES
TO RISE, JARED KUSHNER LED A
HIGHLY AGGRESSIVE EFFORT TO LET
MORE CRIMINALS OUT OF PRISON AND
BACK ONTO THE STREET.
THIS IS RECKLESS.
AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME, IT’S
INSANE IF IT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN
HAPPEN.
THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO SENSE
THAT AND AT TIMES, HE SEEMS
AWARE THAT HE’S BEING LED IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION AND OFTEN
DERIVES KUSHNER AS A LIBERAL AND
THAT’S CORRECT HE IS, BUT HE
CONVINCED THE PRESIDENT THAT
THROWING UP THE PRISONS IS THE
KEY TO WINNING AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTES IN THE FALL AND THAT THOSE
VOTES ARE ESSENTIAL TO HIS
REELECTION.
SEVERAL TIMES OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS, THE PRESIDENT SIGNALED HE
WAS VERY MUCH LIKING TO
CRACKDOWN ON RIOTERS AND THAT’S
THE INSTINCT.
IF YOU WATCH IT YOU BELIEVE IT,
BUT EVERY TIME HE’S BEEN TALKED
OUT OF IT BY JARED KUSHNER AND
AID THAT HE IS HIRED AND
CONTROLLED.
THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS LIKE LOOTING
AND THAT’S WRONG.
NORMAL AMERICANS OF ALL COLORS
HATE LOOTING.
OBVIOUSLY, WHY WOULDN’T THEY
HATE LOOTING?
THEY ARE DECENT PEOPLE.
SO WHAT ARE THE LESSONS OF ALL
THAT WE’VE SEEN AND WE’VE SEEN
SO MUCH OVER THE PAST FIVE DAYS.
IF AMERICA WILL CHANGE BECAUSE
OF THIS AND UNCERTAIN AND WHAT
CAN WE LEARN FROM?
WHAT SHOULD WE DEMAND GOING
FORWARD?
THE FIRST THING TO KNOW IS THAT
WE CAN NO LONGER ACCEPT RACE
BAITING FROM OUR LEADERS.
NEVER.
THAT HAS BECOME SO COMMON NOW
THAT WE BARELY NOTICE IT BUT
IT’S DIVIDING AND DESTROYING THE
COUNTRY AND WE SHOULD MAKE THEM
STOP.
YESTERDAY FOR EXAMPLE, THEY ARE
OF SEATTLE TWEETED THIS AND I’M
QUOTING "I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT MOST MUCH OF THE VIOLENCE
AND DESTRUCTION HERE IN SEATTLE
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN
INSTIGATED AND PERPETRATED BY
WHITE MEN."
IS THAT FACTUALLY TRUE?
WHO KNOWS.
WHO CARES?
THE SKIN COLOR OF CRIMINALS IS
TOTALLY IRRELEVANT TO HOW WE
PROSECUTE THEM FOR THE CRIMES
THEY COMMIT.
IF IT MUST BE IRRELEVANT,
OTHERWISE WE ARE COMMITTING THE
BIGOTRY THAT WE CLAIM TO ABHOR.
YET EVERYWHERE ON TELEVISION AND
SOCIAL MEDIA PROMINENT PEOPLE
ARE TALKING EXACTLY LIKE THIS.
NOT JUST A FEW CRACKPOTS,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, WELL-KNOWN
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE AMPLIFYING RACE HATRED
AT EXACTLY THE MOMENTS THAT WE
NEED IT LEAST AND AT THE MOMENT
WHEN IT’S THE MOST DANGEROUS.
HE WAS THE POLICE CHIEF OF
HOUSTON AND THE FOURTH BIGGEST
CITY OF THE COUNTRY, AND TO HIS
JOB, HIS SWORN DUTY IS TO
ENFORCE THE LAW FAIRLY AND
EVENLY REGARDLESS OF THE
ETHNICITY OF THE SUSPECT.
WATCH THIS AND TELL US IF YOU
THINK HE’S CAPABLE OF DOING
THAT.
IS HE EVEN INTERESTED?
HERE HE IS OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> MY PEOPLE, AS AN IMMIGRANT,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE BUILT THIS COUNTRY!
WE AIN’T GOING NOWHERE!
GOING NOWHERE!
SO YOU GOT HATE IN YOUR HEART
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR, GET OVER IT
IT!
BECAUSE THE CITY IS A MINORITY
MAJORITY CITY!
>> Tucker: MY PEOPLE.
IF A POLICE CHIEF OF ANY COLOR,
ANY COLOR SAID THAT, WE WOULD
ATTACK HIM INSTANTLY AND WE
WOULD MEAN IT.
IT IS WRONG.
WHEN YOU WRONG A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY YOU CAN’T CONSIDER A BOOK
WHAT TO MY PEOPLE" AND CLAIMANT
YOUR PEOPLE DESERVE SOME KIND OF
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION BECAUSE
THEY BUILT THE COUNTRY.
NO, YOUR OBLIGATIONS NOT TO
CONSIDER YOUR PEOPLE BUT ALL
PEOPLE AND CONSIDER THEM EQUALLY
EQUALLY.
HE IS NOT EVEN TRYING TO DO THAT
THAT.
IMAGINE BEING ARRESTED BY THIS
CREEP, THINK YOU GET A FAIR
SHAKE?
THERE’S NOTHING THAT HURTS
AMERICA MORE THAN THAT AND IF
YOU’RE WORRIED ABOUT THE RISE OF
EXTREMISM HERE, AND HONESTLY YOU
SHOULD BE WORRIED, THIS KIND OF
INSANITY IS ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN
TO CAUSE THIS.
LET’S BE CLEAR, WHEN WE SAY
EXTREMISM WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT
UNCONVENTIONAL VIEWS THAT GET
YOU BOUNCED OFF TWITTER OR
SCOLDED BY THE CORPORATE HR
DEPARTMENT.
IF WE MEAN ACTUAL EXTREMISM,
WHERE PEOPLE ESPOUSE VIOLENCE
AGAINST OTHER PEOPLE WHERE LARGE
GROUPS COME TO BELIEVE THEY ARE
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
ABOUT THEM.
NOW, AT THIS MOMENT, NO MATTER
WHAT THEY’RE TELLING YOU AND
CLAIMING FOR POLITICAL
ADVANTAGE, THERE’S NOT A HUGE
AMOUNT OF THAT IN THIS COUNTRY,
THANK GOD.
MOST PEOPLE STILL THINK OF
THEMSELVES AS AMERICANS AND THEY
WANT TO.
BUT IF THE LEFT KEEPS TALKING
LIKE THIS?
THEY ARE DEFINITELY WILL BE AND
VERY SOON.
IFYOU DON’T WANT TO LIVE HERE WH
THAT HAPPENS AND WE SHOULD
DEMAND THEY STOP IMMEDIATELY.
IF ENFORCING THE LAW IS NOT
WHITE SUPREMACY AND INSISTING
THAT EVERYONE IN THE COUNTRY
FOLLOWS THE SAME RULES IS NOT
RACISM.
AND FACT, IT’S THE ANSWER TO
IT IS A QUALITY, EQUALITY UNDER
THE LAW AND IT’S THE ONE THING
THAT WE MUST DEFEND AND IF WE
DON’T, THINGS FALL APART.
IF WEAKNESS INVITES AGGRESSION
AND THAT’S TRUE IN NATURE AND
HUMAN SOCIETY.
OUR LEADERS ARE WEAK, PREDATORS
KNOW IT.
THAT’S WHY THIS IS HAPPENING.
IF YOU LET PEOPLE SPRAY PAINT
OBSCENITIES ON CITY HALL, PRETTY
SOON THERE OVER TONING COP CARS
AND IF YOU PUT UP WITH THAT THEY
WILL COME RIGHT TO THE FRONT
DOOR OF THE POLICE PRECINCT AND
BRING IT DOWN.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW OUT THERE
BEATING PEOPLE TO DEATH AND
SHOPPING MOUNDS.
THEN WHAT?
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE NEXT TIME
THE MOB DOESN’T LIKE SOMETHING